thanks to surf shark for helping support
this episode
hey crazies electronics are pretty
amazing
indoor lighting computers phones
calculators televisions hearing aids
but none of that would be possible
without electric current
it's kind of the life essence of
electronics and every school kid knows
that current takes the path of least
resistance
right well that rule is actually kind of
wrong
[Music]
okay to be fair it's not a hundred
percent wrong
maybe more like 50 it could use some
improvement is what i'm saying
maybe we should start with a
demonstration experiment clone
your time has come okay you talk i work
that's the plan
okay switch on
one of your light bulbs isn't folding
well
[Music]
no it's causing it to spark
[Music]
here's a relatively simple circuit all
these light bulbs are connected by wires
on both sides
the circuit diagram would look something
like this
there's also a multimeter so we can
measure any electric current we want
these bulbs have different wattage
ratings which means they have different
resistances
if the current takes the path of least
resistance we'd expect it to pass
through this bulb
so let's measure the electric current in
each bulb and see what happens
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as we can see the current did take the
path of least resistance
but it also took every other path it
took
every closed path that was available
and that makes perfect sense if you
think about it
if water was flowing slowly and steadily
down a stream
but encountered a split you wouldn't
expect the water to only take the bigger
path
it's gonna take both the same thing
happens with electric current in a
circuit
if there's a path it can take it's going
to take it
it went through every available path in
this circuit
it just didn't do that in equal amounts
there's more current
in the paths with less resistance
so let's try rewriting this rule current
takes the path of least resistance
incorrect more current takes the path of
less resistance
but some current takes each and every
path
it's not nearly as catchy as the
original but at least it's correct
maybe an acronym fuller
bisque tape
nope never mind where was i
oh right uh to understand this rule we
need to dig a little deeper
electric current or just current for
short is the flow of electric charge
you can imagine a bunch of tiny balls or
some kind of fluid
neither is 100 accurate but they're both
good enough for today
this charge does obey certain rules
fundamental rules
like the conservation of charge in
science
conservation just means keeping things
the same so
conservation of charge just means the
amount of charge stays the same
and no exceptions this time because
quantum mechanics
seriously i did a whole video on it if
you can handle some math
speaking of math here's the conservation
of charge
yes i know that can look a little
overwhelming if you've never seen
anything like this before
perfectly normal reaction but i'm gonna
explain
every little individual piece and we're
gonna visualize them as we go
so it'll make sense by the time i'm done
okay so this greek letter rho
is charge density that's how closely
packed the charge is
if it's tightly packed then the density
is big
if it's loosely packed the density is
low
this t on the bottom stands for time
which means this whole fraction
is how density changes in time if the
density isn't changing
the fraction is zero if the density is
going up the fraction is positive
if the density is going down the
fraction is negative
not so bad so far right we all kind of
understand how density works
next this triangle right here means
changes in space
when that triangle is followed by a dot
we're only concerned with into
and out of a space for all you math
nerds out there we're talking about
divergence
the j is the electric current remember
that's just the flow of electric charge
that means this whole thing tells us how
much charge is moving into
or out of a space visually let's imagine
a sphere enclosing a volume of space
if charge is flowing into the sphere we
get a negative number
if charge is flowing out of the sphere
we get a positive number
if just as much charge flows in as flows
out
we get a zero answer now let's put it
all together
all this equation says is that if charge
is getting more or less
dense in one spot over time then that's
because charge flowed into or out of
that spot
seriously that's it that's all it says
electric charge can't be created or
destroyed
so we know any change in density is the
result of a flow and that flow
is how all electronics work that's why
we call it electronics
they're based on the flow of electrons
circuit design is
all about predicting where this electric
current will go
back in 1845 a guy by the name of gustav
kirkoff
based one of his circuit laws on this
principle of charge conservation
but he made one more assumption
so what's this extra assumption he made
that the electric current is
very well behaved he assumed that every
part of a circuit has a consistent
amount of charge
it's not going to bunch up anywhere or
pop out of the circuit
the flow is nice and steady to put this
in terms of what we were just talking
about
he assumed the charge density doesn't
change
how accurate is that well pretty
accurate actually
i mean it's not always true off the top
of my head
high voltage long distance lines are an
exception the charge actually bunches up
and spreads out in a kind of wavy
pattern
but that's an extreme case for ordinary
everyday electronics
steady current is a reasonable
assumption and that leaves us with just
the flow term and the conservation of
charge
the total flow into or out of a volume
is zero
or better yet the flow into a volume
equals the flow out of that volume since
electric current
is that flow we can say the current in
equals the current out
that's kirchhoff's current law or
kirchhoff's junction rule as i like to
call it
it goes by a lot of names what's a
junction
it's kind of like a fork in the road you
mean like this
no no no not literally a fork in the
road it's a metaphor
it's just a visual analog see it kind of
looks like the prongs of a fork
any time there are three or more wires
coming together at a single point
we call it a junction say there's an
imaginary sphere surrounding a junction
no matter what the current entering that
sphere must equal the current that exits
we know that because of kirchhoff's
junction rule
technically it applies everywhere
including the middle of a straight wire
that just isn't very interesting we
don't actually need the rule unless
there's a junction
if a single charge comes across a
junction it has to make a choice
which path does it take we don't know
what each individual charge will do in
that situation
it's random but not equally random
we do notice some patterns when we look
at what a bunch of charges will do
remember more current takes the path of
less resistance
but some current takes each and every
path
if we know the resistances of each path
we can make a prediction
about how much current will go that way
more resistance
means less current and vice versa as you
can see
the new rule matches our experiment
really well
just remember every path is going to
have some current in it
including birds on power lines power
lines are not
insulated so even though they have less
resistance than the bird
there is a little current passing
through that bird
i wonder what that feels like it
probably feels better than companies
watching your browsing habits
today's sponsor surf shark can help with
that surf shark is a vpn or virtual
private network which
adds an extra level of encryption to
your internet experience
to be fair most of your data is already
encrypted on all modern websites
this little lock protects you from a lot
of hurt but there is some information
that's still available
like the base urls of the websites you
visit
that information is regularly used by
your service provider to throttle your
connection
and by all kinds of advertisers to serve
you directed personal ads
all of that feels kind of dirty if you
ask me like
get out of my business people with surf
shark you can put a stop to all that
but you know what maybe there's a
website or two you actually want to
bypass the vpn like when you're watching
science assignment videos on youtube
surf shark has a split tunneling feature
just add the specific url to the safe
list
and it won't use the vpn if you're
interested go to the link in the
description and enter promo code asylum
you'll get 83
off and three extra months for free
which is a good deal
it'll also let surf shark know you heard
about them for me which helps out the
channel
so how shocking was this news about the
current rule
let us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to all my
patreon patrons and youtube members for
making all this possible
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us until next time
remember
it's okay to be a little crazy we're
done now right
i can stop working yeah okay cool
oscar said he would have been happier if
we had mentioned the word mass
at least once in the last video i was
trying to keep the video
focused on weight versus normal force
mass isn't even a force so it can't be
measured on a fourth scale
although based on the bad comments i've
been getting maybe that was a mistake
anyway thanks for watching